by the grace of Allah subhah wa ta'ala
the response has been overwhelming to
say the very least alhamdulillah we've
had social media personalities and
respected Scholars sh from many parts of
the Muslim world promoting the cause we
have raised almost 1.4 million
alhamdulillah and we haven't been
sitting idly waiting to hit our Target
of 2 million we have fully purchased
four properties in London transferred
their ownership to the W after the help
of Allah subhanahu wa taala none of this
would be possible without your support
so we thank you once again this is our
update to yourselves we encourage you to
stay tuned for more updates now that the
work alhamdulillah is truly underway
to arrest the leaders of this genocide
bii and all the leaders who are
committed this genocide this is a great
day for Humanity while the world is
waking up to the Zionist crimes we as
Jewish people we are here to say that
while the zionists are hiding into our
religion to justify all these crimes and
of course they will acuse accuse the IC
and the judge of the IC as anti-semitic
we are here as Jewish people to say that
Zionism have nothing to do with Judaism
it's not anti-semitic to stand up why we
are seeing and witnessing ongoing
genocide taking place in front of the
whole world this is unacceptable every
righteous person have a duty to stand up
and to say no to this genocide
especially we as Jewish people while
they are hiding in our religion they
hijack our identity to justify all this
crime by the grace of Allah subhah wa
ta'ala the response has been
overwhelming to say the very least
alhamdulillah we've had social media
personalities and respected Scholars sh
from many parts of the Muslim world
promoting the cause we have raised
almost 1.4 million alhamdulillah and we
haven't been sitting idy waiting to hit
our Target of 2 million we have fully
purchased for properties in London
transferred their ownership to the W
after the help of Allah subhanahu wa
taala none of this would be possible
without your support so we thank you
once again this is our update to
yourselves we encourage you to stay
tuned for more updates now that the work
alhamdulillah is truly underway